the Joe Rogan experience its what's so
fascinating to me when you think about
people that explore the boundaries of
what a human body's capable of and
strongman is like what there's like guys
who do like David Goggins that do like
the ultra marathons but strongman is
like that's another form of this extreme
pushing of the boundaries of what the
body is capable and when you look at the
progression of the sport it just hasn't
slowed down like if anything it's gotten
even like the weights keep getting
heavier every year everybody keeps
getting faster and like all those like
when the [ __ ] is this gonna stop you
know like we show up to a contest now
like alright we there was literally a
contest in 2018 where the deadlift was
880 pounds for reps wait what's the [ __ ]
dude there was a [ __ ] that
pulled over 5 is so much crazy and so
it's like all of us are like where does
it stop like does it stop you know like
the the log press world record is 502
pounds overhead right now you know it's
just like these crazy outlandish numbers
but like the people like we keep doing
them so I guess we're doing it to
ourselves to a point I guess so but do
you like what is pushing it is it just
that you is it a preconceived idea of
what's possible and now that the bar has
been moved and now you realize that or
is it just that people are more
scientific about their training now I
think that's what it is I think it's um
and it's also like when you the illusion
of equipment over the years you know
like with rogue being water main
equipment sponsor now they make all
strongman equipment so like regular
people have strongman equipment in their
gyms you know they're like PT clinics
that have farmers handles in them for
people to work on core musculature and
posture when they're walking so I think
just like the general availability of
strongman equipment has made it easier
for people to train it more regularly
and get better at the events because you
we have to practice you know like being
strong is great but you have to be able
to manipulate the movement and
manipulate the implement too
and that's where just like the training
in the practice portion of it comes in
so I think that's why we've seen you
know a lot of these weights being pushed
so much further because everybody pretty
much has regular access to these
strongman implements now mmm it just
it's interesting to me that you're
saying that the weights are getting
heavier and people are getting faster
it's like then I'm thinking like how
long have people been doing this when
was the first strongman competition
I mean strongman dates back to like the
1700s really well yeah kind of [ __ ] like
barrel throws and yeah really I mean
when Rob was on you know he was talking
about the show strongest man in history
that was just on History Channel and
they they went back into the history
books to look at old you know
quote-unquote strongmen doing these
strengths these feats of strength all
throughout you know I think one of the
most notable names is Louis Cyr a guy
from Canada who was about my size
actually and is revered to be one of the
strongest men in history and so when he
was doing like these dumbbell lifts and
these back lifts and these hip and thigh
lifts and stuff like that so strongly
it's been around for a long time but
World's Strongest Man didn't become a
thing until the 70s
that's when World's Strongest Man I
think 77 was the first year of world
Strongest Man and that's when it kind of
became a sport you know and not just a
kind of a hobby
I guess so how do they determine what
stuff you're gonna do for the World's
Strongest Man did they I mean did they
have a panel of experts to sit down and
devise each individual event yeah I mean
it's it's come a long way from what it
was in the 70s I mean they used to do
like medleys with like potato sack races
back at world Strongest Man a long time
ago now it's a little more standardized
where they do have like a committee
where it's you know people from the
strongman circuit and judges and stuff
like that but they also bring TV execs
because they want stuff that's gonna
look cool you know be and I think that's
a great thing because you don't want
it's like stuff that is cool to me isn't
gonna look cool to somebody that doesn't
know anything about the sport sometimes
so when they choose the events like
pulling two monster trucks like okay one
it's you have to be strong as [ __ ] to be
able to do it but it also looks really
cool on TV so they try to find that
marriage of both of those things to make
it the most pleasing to the average
participant but also impressive exactly
yeah you know like the deadlift event
they don't have us yes oh this is that's
Marquette that's Marc Felix yeah so this
is one of the world records that he did
and how old is he when he's doing this
this was 53 so this was actually just
this past July this was at a Wembley
Wembley Stadium oh my god or well the
arena in London the hercules hold what a
great name so each of those pillars
weighs 400 pounds and he's just chilling
and you just have to hold it as long as
you can the size of his [ __ ]
shoulders yeah that is preposterous it's
dumb that dude has preposterous muscles
that's okay how long does he hold this
[ __ ] huh he goes over one minute yeah
I mean it's crazy no this is a world
record
what kind of after this is what 122
drops it yeah what kind of breathing you
doing here like does it help to breathe
in deep and heavy or so just during an
event like this it looks 30
that is crazy that's exactly dude black
don't crack the nut lion that guy's
amazing
so with with an event like that it's
more just real and I try to relax and
getting into like a calm mental state
because you don't want to be super
revved up because you're not moving
you're just focusing on your grip and
that's the biggest thing for an event
like that but then there's also events
we're like okay when you're maxing your
deadlift you do have to hold your breath
right so it's different for everything
you do look at it goes up to his wrist
that's a that's incredible that's
amazing though that he could hold those
[ __ ] things for that long was like a
minute I wasn't a minute and 23 seconds
and for reference like I I was at that
contest and did it for like 42 seconds
oh that's crazy now how do you prepare
for someone dead do you like you don't
hold those things like do you just work
on your grip but no usually I'm honestly
self set up like a pulley system in the
gym so use just like regular handles
that use on like a key
machine set up a pulley on like a squat
rack or like one of the rogue rigs have
loading pins coming down stack weights
on that and then just holding yeah or
even just doing something as simple like
pull up holds like dead hangs from a
barbell yeah from a pull-up bar how long
can you dead hang for I've done over a
minute that's impressed okay guys that
heavy yeah yeah so honestly usually
would go my shoulders usually get tired
before anything else just from wounds
yeah just from like holding it and so
[Applause]